how's it going read my name back and
welcome to dead space that are you down
long we're gonna start a solar campaign
let's see what all the fuss is all about
new game I'll be play I can only choose
normal but yeah you brought still
suggest that I play dead space wanted to
but I already fly damn dead space one
was actually like my first horror game
that I ever touched I was so scared when
I play it thanks for downloading the
Dead Space 3 death you are welcome
after breaking up an eerie entry Isaac
wakes up to discover himself stranded on
the hostile plains of tau volantis with
this crew scattered or possibly dead
Isaac's only option is to press forward
in hopeless finding a way to survive
that sounds like you have to press
forward how do we even know that we're
pressing against something huh what are
we present against hah oh we can stomp
babies [ __ ] yeah you know it's a good
game if you can stomp alien babies that
Isaac Isaac is ayat I wanted you to
start from the beginning or if your wha
that it's cold and [ __ ] you'd think a
map cold volcano would be hot but no
come on Isaac
I don't know why but I like Isaac more
when he just had his helmet on it was
more mysterious like who he was I don't
I don't know actually you get to see us
a face in the beginning now that think
about it but isn't it's not clear or
whatever you don't get to stare it's
[ __ ] your face or some [ __ ] like that
I don't like saying it faces you you
like staring at faces is that what
you're staring at mine all right you're
you're too cute
but let's look at the helmet is it gonna
be a bad at helmet we do have a badass
helmet it looks like we've gone through
a lot of [ __ ] already
sweet mother of snow we're in Sweden
holy [ __ ] I didn't think we'd actually
be in Sweden press all right I don't
need your noob tix ah where are John Oh
jump in time BAM
misses one step four pills and a small
step for Isaac Clark or a big step for
Isaac suck air oh [ __ ]
I don't know what I fell about that bras
what the [ __ ] are we going in there
what the [ __ ] is goin out oh stop in
town ma'am ma'am
oh that's right that's what I'm talking
about okay I don't like this press
what's going on
damn that's cuter than ah what the [ __ ]
jump-scare mm what the [ __ ] my ears
exploded I was even looking at that bed
that's what you get for being or [ __ ]
they really stop look at no leg
don't leave me you're my only friend
alright let's go inside and it's what
it's cozy and nice oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay no like everything so
I play Lego Snowdown right
I am this is all so so far all right
what do we got
I am [ __ ] love the stump it's like
the greatest thing ever
Isaac Clark should be in that musical
stomp it be [ __ ] kicking ass I hate
boxes uh such enthusiasm all right what
else we got can we go here doesn't look
like it oh where there's a ladder here
press a
all right full it's not that atmospheric
right now at least in a horror sense
what it says weapon part ha una near
Delhi stabbed louder
god damn jump scares everywhere oh man
my poor oh the stasis
I love the save it how do you shoot it
good job on reloading can I go here ha
oh my [ __ ] dick I don't even know
what I'm supposed to do
Oh get up there Isaac nice going Isaac
go
iiiiii there we go
if it doesn't open head butt that [ __ ]
jesus [ __ ] christ man calm your tits
Isaac you're crazy you're crazy I tell
you
alright so I whoa whoa whoa we are not
safe yet whoa whoa whoa look at that
[ __ ] hostile environment indeed all
right what are we going press and hold
okay weapon part found I want to use it
in the weapon crafting thing all right
did y'all got fake da oh you're not your
top now I am um I'm gonna [ __ ]
alright
more identify hey night-night
reload that bed nein nein nein nein you
do not [ __ ] scared it's okay Jase's
Christ
all right MA did Isaac say [ __ ]
you can't swear Isaac this is a chat no
wait did not alright it ed an open area
I don't trust this one second ah so part
of the Eugene used to connect with this
I don't know if I like sure do you try
that I'm not going to do it in the demo
but if I play the game I'll probably try
it out just for fun hey what's up man
I I [ __ ] your mom that's how I got
here
machetes his mommy's after him
right there headed my way
oh no bueno what what
oh okay we're good Kinesis Greg ah run
the room with the survivals aim and
press oh cool
alright I nail that [ __ ] alright this
is a I'll pick the Arctic suits just for
fun why don't we got hey wha
um that's kind of badass actually Isaac
look cooler now as well cool I'll take
that place let's try the bench or
whatever millet teslic or heavy standard
all right we got a lot of stuff oh yeah
we saw this and okay what can we upgrade
exactly all right
it looks like we're heading out I'm
running around in a snowstorm I'm
running around in its own star I'm gonna
get butt-fucked Oh nurse elevator well
that was good
I enjoyed that little song hope you
enjoyed as well I know I'm I'm gonna
hopefully when I'm done with YouTube um
I want to become a singer I'm gonna sing
in Las Vegas I'm [ __ ] dude what the
ow tentacles I hate tentacles hi it's
him again
okay all right he broke the elevator I
hope it's really proud of himself
whoa whoa no no boss battle I don't like
what I'm out of here
nope Oh what the [ __ ] is those things
ah [ __ ] ah
what the [ __ ] kill that thing I'm not
I'm not sure if that's dead or not wow
wow that really hurts I gotta kill it
ah stop can you stop can you stop for
one second all right
oh that's easy
next one oh [ __ ] come on come on
is that all you got I can't aim where
for [ __ ] dick there we go
Oh what you gonna do now oh [ __ ]
show me your chairs go show me a tenon
hello why are you going
what a [ __ ] fuzzy well at least he
made a bridge on me what a gentleman
thank you sir thank you so much I will
just knew he was a kind sir
I always nerd that's why I shot up his
dicks I think those were his dicks
that's what gentlemen do we shoot it off
each other sex oh you didn't know uh-huh
well you have been missing out my friend